The joe rogan experience.
What is that all law about obscenity?
How do you define upset at me?
That was the,
that's the question in a lot of trials,
right?
Well community standards
and this is why it's,
it's in trouble and by the way,
I would love to know where all like
the fucking libertarian political
organizations where when Max
hardcore went to jail for four years,
cause they nailed him when he,
when he mailed stuff to fucking Tampa,
Florida stinkers type of stuff and they
trapped him and got him on some obscene
community standards thing.
But we always are.
But he's sticking up for Max hardcore.
This guy did for years
for adult pornography.
It's fucking adults.
There was no children involved.
It seems really strange that you could
have something that is not illegal.
That is obviously it's marketable.
I mean whether or not it's healthy
to watch that kind of shit.
It's obviously people are watching it
and there was always an argument that
certain types of depravity keeps people
from committing things in the real life
that they can get through it in some
sort of a fantasy form and it keeps him
from being a creep or a violent
person in their real life.
And if someone signs of
fucking waiver man and what,
where do you cross the line?
Where do you decide that this is something
that this guy needs to get locked in
a cage for?
Cause you don't agree?
Well the whole country is full of shit
when it comes to free speech and free
thought cause all of us,
and I mean I should say all ideologies,
liberal and conservative have an asterisk.
Like you're free to say
this and do this as long as,
and for the liberals,
it's what they call hate speech and
anything that's racial or homophobia.
And for the Conservatives it's,
hey,
don't fuck with God and country.
But both sides are equally phony when
it comes to like when's the last time,
uh,
like you know,
a feminist stuck up for a guy who said
something about women that was unpleasant
because he has the right to say it.
Never like we were all these people
when Tracy Morgan said what he said,
why did nobody who didn't
like him stick up for him?
Oh Gosh,
I think this is like the don't
have that much resources.
So it's not like they can jump into
the fray on for any little situation.
They don't have that much time.
When you're running some sort of an
organization that's looking for violence
against women or anything
but mean you don't have,
you have to look at
concentrate only on that.
I don't fault them for going after or
not going after cases where guys like
Tracy Morgan got [inaudible].
Now they only have a certain amount
of things they want to concentrate on.
But no,
I mean I fault him for
going after him because I,
you know,
he's white like white.
Like when people went after him,
why didn't they just
stick up for him and go,
we don't like what he said,
but he's got the right to say it and
there should be no penalty for it.
That's what I mean.
And none of these groups,
which would take them two seconds
to put out that fucking memo,
but glad has never done it.
None of them have done it.
No,
they,
no,
they don't devote any resources to
helping anybody else out there develop
resources to pushing their ideology and
their ideology is that this guy needs to
be punished,
right?
Because if he's punished and
it cost him a lot of money,
then people are going to
stop thinking like that.
You're going to stop expressing
themselves like that,
which I can see their point it up to a
certain point where you got to realize
like if is,
is it okay,
where does this,
uh,
where's this line happen?
Is it okay for Denzel Washington to play
a murderer and a gangster and a movie?
It is.
Right.
Okay.
Why is it not okay for Tracy Morgan to
portray a guy who's pretending that he
would stab is Sonifi was gay
because he's not telling the truth.
He's,
he's gay.
He's obviously doing a character that
is like completely over the top and says
ridiculous shit all the time.
That is,
that's his shtick.
I'll,
by the way,
I was incorrect when I apologize.
You just straighten me out.
When I said the women's groups,
I should have said the gay groups.
I was thinking that it was,
Tracy said something that was anti woman.
I forgot that it was that.
I actually forgot what I
just went with the conflict.
I'm saying why doesn't the group who's a,
you're saying that gay dudes are women.
Um,
so all the great ones are,
I mean,
let's be honest,
who hasn't seen a transsexual
and fallen in love?
It's an open society folks.
Yeah,
I think Tracy got you.
People have to understand that there's
people that want to see him do that.
You might not like it,
but it's like dice.
I'd love dice.
I've always loved dice.
I want to see him go fucking bananas.
It's a form of entertainment.
And if he does it about Italians,
which I am,
I will,
I will laugh.
I will laugh along with it.
Cause I know,
you know,
if he's making fun of us,
it's,
it's mostly true shit,
you know.
But for whatever reason,
some people want to pretend that you know,
some of his ridiculous over the
top stereotypes aren't funny.
It's like that's a crew
delirious character.
This character of fucking
hates that break man.
I love it.
It's great entertainment.
I,
you know,
swallow my load yet chew.
It takes that seriously.
Why would you be angry?
This guy,
why?
I mean it's,
this is just,
this is entertainment.
It's comedy and it's a,
it's a valid form of comedy and
this is where it gets weird.
It's like when you,
when a guy's creating art and to break,
believe it or not,
Tracy Morgan's creating fucking art when
he gets on stage and he does standup
you,
he's not trying to
fucking piss people off.
He's just going with,
this is one of the,
this is one of the styles of comedy.
You say completely outrageous shit.
We all know guys who would sit like
Brian Holtzman is one of my perfect
examples.
You need,
do you know Brian?
Sure.
I'm saying the Harry's.
Yeah.
He did a joke about Susan Smith after,
after Susan Smith got caught drowning.
He goes on stage like two
days later and he goes,
the Susan Smith case
and she'd drawn a kid.
Yeah,
I heard those were bad kids.
I heard they sat that close to the TV.
They always spelt a fucking milk.
They don't put away their blocks.
Those kids will not be missed and we were
laughing and gang the whole audience.
It was a combination of laughs and
gasps and that's a valid piece of art.
That's a valid piece of art.
He doesn't really mean that he doesn't,
if he had to choose,
he would say,
yes,
please go back in time and stop
her before she tells her children.
He's a character.
He's playing a crazy
accentuated character.
He gets into a zone and he does this,
this thing on stage and he says like
really offensive shit and it's fucking
funny and I enjoy it.
It's art or even when you're just being
yourself and exploring a ridiculous
concept.
But we never,
people never stick up for that.
And the same people that would defend
maple Thorpe or any other form of art,
piss Christ in a jar are the same.
There's the same mentality that will
attack Tracy or that will attack,
ah,
I missed what he said,
or Michael Richards.
It's a fraudulent stance
and every side does it.
It drives me fucking crazy.
I think there's,
yeah,
it's cause cause people have this idea,
a lot of people I should say have this
idea that if you don't agree with them,
you're wrong and your,
your,
uh,
if you're,
you're against them.
You don't,
it's not like you can enjoy different
things or have different ideas about
different standards of living
and what you shouldn't,
shouldn't be able to do.
No,
it's not that.
It's,
if you don't agree,
you're wrong.
And people have to understand that
different people like different shit.
Right.
And you can't force
someone to not like porn.
You can't force someone
to say you're not gay.
You know,
you,
you cannot be gay.
We're not all,
you can't do that.
It doesn't work.
Like you have to let people do whatever
the fuck they want to do and then you
just got to kind of
accept that that's them.
And I wish a lot of
these phony artists like,
and I say phony,
like,
I mean many singers,
I think that they're hit
by attacking Christianity.
Like I have no prob attack Christianity
fucking shorts right there.
But it's like none of them address Islam.
None of them are addressed.
The fact that they're afraid to attack is,
and that's what drives me crazy
because it's this fucking fake edge.
It's the,
it's this fucking fake.
I'm being dangerous.
But it's really,
they're looking both ways before they
cross the street and they're acting like
they just bolted out the front
door and it fucking drives me.
It drives me nuts.
Yeah.
It's the,
the,
there's a certain amount
of posturing that people,
uh,
people get into when they start talking
about certain political issues and
certain things and certain ideologies.
And it gets to like that gross place
where people just start clapping and you
can tell they're disingenuous.
And it just,
there are milking off this
thing for their own ego.
They're milking off this reality for
their own ego instead of just sort of
trying to,
you know,
trying to look at the
big picture because the,
the big,
you mean what?
You're absolutely right.
Why doesn't anybody want
to make fun of Islam?
I'll tell you why.
Because they'll fucking kill you.
Yeah.
Like they took shit to an
entirely different place
and so anybody who wants to
pretend to be edgy,
it doesn't involve going that far.
I mock them but I mean I can,
I'm careful where I put
the Joe come out an idiot.
You know crazy though.
You right now just admitted to
self censorship for the same thing.
You just find it more reasonable because
you say that your take on it as well
are,
you know,
I'll take it back a little bit,
as far as I know,
but you are clearly saying
that you wouldn't say what
you'd normally would want
to say because they're dangerous.
Sure.
But,
but I will say that that's
why I'm not saying it.
Isn't that amazing.
It's a terrifying thing in 2012 that we
still have a faction of our world that
you have to literally
can't draw their guy.
But I also won't say other
things on stage for feeling like,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
a nigger is a rough word to pull out.
You better have a reason
before you say that on stage.
You can't just go out.
And I would never say
it an anger at somebody,
but it's like every,
everything has lines and stuff
and reasons I don't say it.
And I do self sensor and I
think we all do as comics.
You Ha you have to.
We're not crazy,
but I never want people
panelize when they don't.
That's the difference.
Yeah.
Well it's horrible.
You ready to,
of course record.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?